hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong what's up mark
how you doing i am so so great today
jacqueline and one of the many reasons
is because our special guest today
not only am i a huge fan of his talented
acting ability but it's also a former
showdown competitor once upon a time oh
wow yeah i was trying not to bring it up
but bro you're going down and i'm just
thinking about it and i really want to
go back on the show because i think i
destroy you now like i feel like i've
even since then i went through a deep
dive of just all movies ever and i just
feel like i would win now that's why i
remember what i lost on i lost on kung
fu panda who was the voice
yeah wow jane fonda and i know i was
wrong do you remember who it was i don't
remember who angelina jolie maybe
oh my
and i make other people answer them so
as everyone is trying to figure out who
we're talking about because he just
doesn't need any introduction of course
i'm talking about alex wolfe you guys
know him from jumanji you know him from
hereditary and he actually has two new
films in theaters right now pig with
nicholas cage but we're here to talk to
him about old because on today's episode
we're going to be breaking down some of
m night shyamalan's filmography because
old opens this week so before we bring
you back in alex and find out what is
your favorite sort of m night film we're
gonna go ahead and talk about his
highest rated film with our segment we
like to call two minutes with tim take
it away
[Music]
thank you jaclyn m night shyamalan
seemed to come out of nowhere there he
had a feature under his belt the coming
of age comedy wide awake the sixth sense
marked him as a director to watch and i
know it's a cliche but
it was a movie that everybody was
talking about the sixth sense was the
second highest grossing film of 1999
behind only star wars episode 1 the
phantom menace and though initially they
might not seem to have much in common
the sixth sense was among a number of
films released that year that had
audiences questioning the basic reality
of the narratives that they were
watching a list that includes the matrix
fight club the blair witch project and
being john malkovich among others it's
certified fresh at 86 on the tomato
meter with 158 reviews and it has a 90
audience score
so what did the critics have to say in a
fresh review jay boyer of the orlando
sentinel wrote not only does this
production contain what is probably
willis's strongest performance and a lot
of other fine acting but it is also one
of the best films of the year and it's
sure to be a movie that the people who
see it will want to talk about however
in a rotten review jeff weiss of salt
lake city's deseret news wrote if there
was ever a movie that could be accused
of being both too subtle and too
heavy-handed at the same time it would
be the sixth sense
the rt critics consensus reads and might
shine milan's the sixth sense is a
twisty ghost story with all the style of
a classic hollywood picture but all the
chills of a modern horror flick so
that's the sixth sense
jaclyn
mark
i'm ready to communicate with you now
take it away
[Laughter]
oh tim i i really love um tim when he
breaks it down especially when he pulls
themes because i didn't realize how much
at that time period we were basically
like is this real life
is this reality like that's like a cool
pool theme i liked it alex well again i
introduced you but welcome because i
love that you had to come in here and
like defend your showdown honor before
we even got your name new yorker of me i
just thank you just kind of yelled at
your
your co-host for no reason
i appreciate it actually because that's
actually just cinephile nerdness i know
i i'm gonna go ahead and say now based
on this i got a game for christmas
called cinephile the card game and it's
like cards against humanity styling
i played it in la um
and i beat all my friends
um shots if we didn't get an answer we
made a drinking game the cinephile game
and i was okay trashed and they were
like name every they were like name
every bergman movie from i was like
here's my bread and butter
wow strawberry that's the story going on
and on
i love it
i'm putting a shot out here that i want
to i want to make this trio cinephile at
my place mark's in the neighborhood
we're in the valley when you get back to
la we're gonna make it happen but right
now we're gonna talk about first your
favorite m night film
go ahead and break it down because i was
surprised at this one which one is it
for you it's the visit
yeah
so when did you first see it and like
how did it capture you that's part of it
i mean that's that is always part of the
experience and that i i saw a million of
them in theaters and i you know have
grown up with his films but the visit
caught me in a moment where
i think um
i don't know what it was except that you
know i always see god i don't even know
five or six movies in the theater like a
week like i'm crazy about it i love
going to the theater and i think i'd
seen a back to back just movies that
hadn't surprised me or movies or i don't
remember how old i was but i went with
my whole group of friends we said okay
we're gonna see the visit because i've
loved every single night movie um cause
i was a kid and so it was big for us my
friends and i always would go see the
night movie but this one we went in kind
of thinking
this one looks different this there's
something about this that looks like and
i have never been so
audibly um responsive to a movie i've
never enjoyed a movie in the theater as
much as i enjoyed the visit and also i
found that um
their performances in it the two kids
it's just some of like the finest young
people acting i've seen in a while her
talking about how much she hates her
face while the camera is just zooming in
on her and i just found it to be so
creative and it put every other found
footage film even in its arena to shame
in my opinion that is so by far the best
found footage film i've ever seen and i
think um
i don't know i just i just adore it
that's just plain and simple i just
think it's
pretty much a perfect movie and we won't
even get into the twist because i like
people to keep that as super but that's
my favorite twist in any movies since
like the 70s i think it's like the best
wow mark i saw you nodding i can tell
you're about this do you agree are you
are you i was i was going to compliment
both the young people acting and the old
people acting in this movie it's just
it's a completely
cross-generational masterpiece for that
reason and it's also just
the girl and she's incredible
she's so good with her with her facial
expressions and just the way that she
conveys a range of emotion but overall
this movie was so exciting for me as
somebody who was a huge shyamalan fan
right out of the gate with with the big
three those first three huge movies
sixth sense unbreakable signs and then
he went off and started doing some
different types of films and you're just
sort of waiting for that comeback pitch
you're waiting for that for that big par
putt for sports fans and this was it
because you get in the theater and you
just have no idea what to expect it's
like well he used to give us a cool
twist i don't know if that's going to
happen with this movie and when it
happens i agree with you alex i think
it's right up there with some of the
best work he's done with with one of the
cooler theater experiences i've ever had
just because we knew to prepare for
something but we didn't know it was
going to be there
and you know and i don't even we won't
even get into it but it's such a simple
twist it's such a
of course of course
but that to me is the most miraculous
and majestic of filmmaking is when oh of
course that's what the amazing
hitchcockian twist is but i didn't see
it coming
at all it's just because you think are
you allowed to do that like are you
allowed to go and the way it's done i'm
just i just
i mean i can't get over also you know
i've talked to him a lot about that
movie i was just gonna say how much have
you nerded out with him about this movie
i've nerded out about all of his movies
but i felt like um you know like i feel
like i have borrowed time to geek out
about his movies because you know we're
making a movie and and uh i have to you
know i want i'm his friend too so we
have a lot of things to talk about our
families whatever and i'm like okay if
we're gonna slot in any geek out time i
want to talk about the visit anytime i
can
and so
i interviewed him at tribeca for like a
retrospective of his work oh wow and um
he chose me which was like the most
amazing like you're coming for my gig
son can you not be this talented like
you do the writing directing and acting
can you give me the interview please
no i'm so sorry i'm gonna and i'm gonna
beat him at schmo down oh my god by the
way i discovered it's the hardest job in
the world interviewing it's by far the
hardest job i mean it it is by far the
hardest and it's and you have to stay
the most focused and you have to answer
and i saw your amazing uh q a with um
didn't you do a q a for the lighthouse
yeah i did i did
that and i thought that was one of my
favorites where you just were tremendous
at geeking out and amazing and i watched
that a lot as preparation i watched a
lot of things to get myself ready but
when i was interviewing him i asked him
about the visit it's kind of a moving
story he said that he showed the visit
um and not one company bought it not one
company was interested in it at all and
he went home and he said he was just at
the lowest point in his life he said he
was so depressed he felt like you know
maybe i've lost it maybe i've you know
any any and i forget if it was liko or
shauna one of his daughters was putting
together a little jigsaw puzzle and he
sat down and you know he just started
putting the puzzle pieces together just
one after another he thought how that
let's just do something to distract
ourselves and then he said for whatever
reason it triggered something of you
know what what what if
what if i can make it better you know
what if it's not them like and what if i
can make this movie a lot better and so
he said he went into the editing bay and
started to make each scene just a little
better every single day and he started
to just cut and cut and make it better
and better and better and finally he
said wow this is oh this is way better
now like i could have made it way better
before now it's way better and uh many
showed it and it got bought i forgot if
it was
evil weinstein or one of those guys but
whatever it is it was bought and and i
think it made the most money of
any of the movies and brought him back
to his roots it was oh the thing i
appreciated i loved the movie but i
always loved the stories behind the
movies like if i ever do anything that's
what i want to do is like did you know
this little thing that everyone forgot
but lives free in my brain and for him
on that one i actually spoke to him
about it too and he talked about he's
like i wanted to remove all of the
distractions of making a big budget film
because he said i felt like i lost a lot
of what made me excited about filmmaking
and doing the visit he said it was like
it just reinvigorated me and i was like
i just love hearing an artist really
look at their work in that way and
really look at
finance movies at that point yeah yeah
and so nobody gets fine and i don't see
how much pressure that puts on someone
because the the budget for that movie is
reported somewhere around five million
dollars of his own cheddar and so when
you invest that much of yourself into it
that is so much pressure to have the
movie perform well but also to sort of
you know add to your legacy the movie
ended up doing like you said alex almost
a hundred million dollars worldwide so
just as far as profitability goes that's
a guy you want to invest in yeah i mean
yeah honestly though it's funny like
in some ways i think he sees it as less
of a risk i mean i would love to ask him
about that in the financing because for
some reason i never i felt like that
would was prying or something to ask
about that but i'd love to know is it
more pressure
um to put your own money in you know and
you have like because i think what they
did was he took a mortgage out on his
house maybe it's like a second period
yeah i think he took a mortgage out on
his house and said let's do this and
basically bet his life on it and i'm
sure that's um a big risk and i'm sure
there's a lot of pressure but i think
that part of it was that he had too much
pressure and too many cooks in the
kitchen before that and by the way i
want to go on record as saying i think
that everyone is batch crazy for
ignoring some of the
amazing films in that little period of
time that uh by the way can i just say
i'm actually a defender and like people
y'all can come for me if you want but i
know why i like it but i had fun with
this airbender
i'm like i really had fun with it
those those fans are gonna come for us i
don't know what to do with it because
yeah i i do believe that
it is a different type of thing it does
have things about it maybe that are not
as strong as unbreakable or something
but to write off last airbender or to
write off um uh to write off which i
think the happening is such an amazing
dark comedy which has got so much wild
things i think that in some ways
he
it's not just that he had all the studio
distractions i think he was
experimenting with a different kind of
cinema i think he was having fun being
both
spielberg and kurosawa and trying to
meld all these kind of genres and i get
pissed off if anybody talks about way
before i was in the movie so that's why
i was kind of kismet that it came to me
but way before that i would get always
pissed off if anybody would try and
write off any section of his movies
which i think most people respect him of
course as the great author of our
generation i just think that um
he just has this this beautiful um
defiance and and uh bravery in all his
movies that i feel like he should just
be looked at as the collective work as
one of the great authors of our
generation i think that it's like you
know um the happening is like he's like
barry lyndon or something going on way
off the map and doing something like
crazy bergman in the middle of his
career made a couple weirdo comedies and
like you know
made the devil's way or whatever that
movie is that that people just panned in
the middle of his career are winter like
that's old school filmmaking old school
filmmakers were not defined by what we
like to define them i mean looking at
you know even what wilder you know
wilder everyone's like yeah he does
romance but like the sun like you're
looking at like sunset boulevard in
comparison to the apartment you could
not
literally say to yourself that that was
the same filmmaker it's so great
real quick we want to touch on a couple
more things about the visit before we
get to old because i want people to
to definitely experience this movie and
hear what you have to say about it but
what's your favorite scene from the
visit like if you wanted to sort of sum
up why you find it to be so visionary
and i don't want to give it away the end
so
i won't give it away the end is my it's
like my favorite thing night's ever done
i think it's
just so amazing um the end and then also
the scene where the camera's zooming in
on her and he says why do you always
look in the mirror i forget what he says
but it's just the scene between a
brother and sister where there's not
even a there's not even a splash of
horror or genre on it it's just a great
scene between a brother and sister i
also love the when the scene where the
kids are playing under the house and
there's and they're sort of crawling
around and then they they they capture
something on camera what the hell was
that because i grew up sort of in the
wilds of virginia where like one of the
fun places to play and make a fort is
under the house and so you go under
there and you're just hoping to not run
into a snake you have no idea you're
going to see a creepy grandma just crawl
through it's just like
that is one of those ripples that goes
through a theater where i i liken that
to the first time we see the shark in
jaws where it's like okay we we do not
trust anything happening anymore yeah
and i'm on the edge of my seat it was
just such a cool way to do it 80 minutes
in it's not like it's like isn't that
late in the game like we know all about
there's all these things like
can you clean the the oven right right
can you go clean the oven there's things
like that that are pinched and then at
the end i love also that
knight is so not a naval gazer like
knight doesn't give a [ __ ] he's like you
know what i'm making this this is a
horror movie now you know like no
guys for thinking i'm just gonna stay in
my little arty zone he's like no i i
spread it out i rosemary's babied it and
now get ready to scream this is what
we're here for you know i really do love
that too um i i think it's going to be
hard but i'm going to make you do this
because i'm not going to let you rank
the movie that you're in sorry uh and i
know rankings you want to like do it all
but what's your what how does this rank
for you like where what's the top three
of m night for you
i think it's the best i'm just trying to
veer away because i don't want to hype
it i think it's the best i mean i want
you guys to see it but i think um
if people go for it or people don't it
really doesn't matter that's how good it
is i think this movie is going to be
stand
in a mosaic of the more interesting
movies of the past 10 15 years i mean i
think it's easily is most unique but i
would put the night shyamalan movies in
a category and then i'd put old a
totally separate category because so
does the visit top the m night ones then
i know it's a thinker
no no no i'm gonna
you know what it'll make him happy i
love signs unbreakable and and sixth
sense i love the happening i love the
village i love these movies but i'm just
gonna be crazy and say the top three
without an order because i just can't do
it is visit split and old and i feel
like it's really fun to just be like
yeah his later work to me it stands out
as like even more i think like it's on
par with like altman like later altman
like experimental kind of like images or
like three women or something like i
feel like he's just
at his prime in my opinion and i can
champion old a little bit too because i
i had the pleasure of seeing old in a
theater it's it's everywhere as of july
23rd
and it was a very weird movie to see i
literally screened the movie on my
birthday which is a very weird thing to
have happen because as you're getting
older that day you're also watching
weird stuff happening on the beach with
agents i don't want to talk to alex
about this because he's wise beyond his
years ladies and gentlemen he is i don't
think he's reached a quarter century yet
which seriously pisses me off because
he's doing more movies than me
yeah but like you have friends in a life
like it changes
how lonely i am
stop stop
oh no that's so great um real quick
though about old um what i love about m
knights movies even more than the movies
themselves is how genius of a marketer
he is with his films i know he is very
involved because he's one of the
producers and how it comes out and i've
loved the way they've teased old where
you don't know a ton
but
give me like kind of um what's your
little amuse boosh for it to sort of
like let folks know what they maybe not
plot points but what they have in store
for them with old
i am going to plead beg by the way this
is so fun
so i've been doing press
for like weeks and weeks and this is by
far the most fun we can just geek out of
my movies but for me it's like
the more
i i i use the metaphor of like you know
there's those there's like that science
experiment where if you stare at
something you can't see it and then you
look away and you see the little dot in
the corner i feel like the more people
try not to
put this movie in any category and try
to look too directly at it and more just
lay back and let the movie happen to you
and just
sign up for it and don't and don't try
and put it in any genre or or um
uh have too much of
comparisons or anything go into this
movie blind and you will have the time
of your life and i think it will link
with you because even people come out
and go well i don't know is this
just slowly an hour so later i catch
them staring at the window going that
one scene you know it's just one of
these things that it it sticks with you
you know it's got it's got a scent it
stays with you in a fun way my easy
question about old for you alex is look
you're a very hard-working actor you're
you're on set all the time and people
who work hard need a good vacation does
this movie at any point make you rethink
where your next vacation might take
place
i mean i want to go there and speed up
time and it would be fun i want to go
there uh with you guys
dude just sit and play move you all get
to that beach about two hours before i
do and then it'll all be even
i mean honestly though too like i just
want an outdoor projector on a beach
playing movies at night every night and
then like you know
and then we can die fast why not yeah
i'm about it fire pit i'll bring an
acoustic guitar it'll be like the
opening scene from jaws uh never mind
i'm sorry i can't go i'm so sorry mark
is bringing a guitar
oh no
i just learned the e chord i'm going
through the tunnel
we are gonna get you out of here too in
just a couple minutes because you are
very busy yeah again everyone please
check out old per alex's direction in a
theater as quickly and as soon as
possible that you can do that please
check it out but i have to ask you this
because
still to this day you rank i did an
interview with alex uh for five favorite
films which is this series where we
asked filmmakers to do and it was for
alex's film because he's also director
ladies and gentlemen and what was so
interesting is it was the longest
interview i've ever done it took me like
oh my god like a half a day to
transcribe it so i have to honestly ask
you about movie recommendations before
you get out of here because oh my god
man sees everything ladies and gentlemen
and that is rivaling someone who is
literally paid to watch movies
i um i have some weird ones and some not
so weird ones that i've just seen
they're not my like necessarily my
favorite movies just movies i've seen
recently that i thought were really
fascinating and good i saw a movie that
um i'm really curious we think called a
common crime that just came out um
it's a spanish movie it's it's kind of
scary actually i i um
i found it um pretty disturbing and i
thought it was very cubrican and kind of
um
mysterious and and fun uh and and i
really liked that um i'm i'm a total
idiot and i just saw all that jazz for
the first time i've never seen it yeah
i'm just giving some fun recommendation
of saw all that jazz um i i've now gone
through
um the entire
eric romer um uh collection so he's this
amazing french um filmmaker who will put
you on a much nicer beach than old you
know he makes all these summer movies
that have all these personal conflicts
that i just am addicted to it's like
it's like
it's like for me it's like reading harry
potter i just get like lost in the world
and just keep so i've seen every single
one except the um the period ones the
ones back in the day because
occasion you have to be in the right
mood to see a period movie so that that
uh all those are fantastic like pauline
at the beach
um
uh uh
a summer tale um my night at mods is so
romantic so great yeah and he's like
just post new wave right like that was
when his heyday was like just later i
mean some of them are new-ish
really 90s yes
much later so i mean he's just all over
the map incredible um eric romer i saw a
movie called um
one sings the other doesn't by agnes
varda that's so oh yeah
it's so good and such a good story about
you know family and and abortion if you
haven't seen her black panther
documentary you should check it out i
haven't yeah
it was on craigslist i didn't i didn't
see i saw i saw a little thing is it
amazing it is really amazing
on the beaches yes yeah you just got put
on okay i gotta see it no it's so
interesting to see the questions that
she chose to ask
those women at that time because
everyone was focused on the men of the
black panther movement and she chose to
focus on the women and there's like
conversations about natural hair and
just thinking about when she made that
it's so ahead of your time you have
interviewers now that can't really grasp
those
sort of
i would say questions when you're
talking about certain subjects they just
go for the obvious thing and so why do
you think they're scared or something
like shoes
she wasn't scared i think she just
approached it from a people standpoint
because if you the one thing you can say
about her filmmaking she was curious
about things and that's what she chose
to put in front of her and like yeah and
so i just think she let her curiosity
guide her and and also her empathy like
i i got to interview
yeah yeah with facebook
you feel in her movies that she's a
really kind really deep person yeah
and you can't the no film school is
going to teach that that's just no yes
you can't and it's not that you
necessarily have to be super kind to
make a good movie obviously but um i i
sometimes i can feel in the movie like i
can always feel in a cameron crow movie
that he's a really good guy yeah
well
yeah
in his movies you know they're they're
little one of my favorite books fast
times at richmond high is a hard book to
find but if you ever can find it is a
great book um i've never read it i've
just seen the movie and most times of
course yeah no the book is pretty
incredible uh and considering when he
wrote it it's even more
alex so
i just have to say thank you again this
has been really great thank you i want
to nerd out with movies with you as
often as possible you have to go see pig
again you got to go all right i'm going
to go do it i'm going to say that
you're going to be able to see this one
in a theater you need you you want a
theater experience for
yeah
a theater experience for both i know
that knight has really like it's already
like everybody already knows to go see
that in the theater but pig
a seemingly small movie is really
gorgeous and really has a scope and and
i'm proud of it and
go see nicholas cage's most incredible
nuanced emotional performance um that
i've ever seen i think it's just a
really a love story between two friends
who need each other what's the next um
what's the next three three-letter movie
you think you're gonna make
yeah i've literally decided i'm only
gonna make three-letter one-word movie
i mean one-word movies especially like
hereditary this
i mean you really don't even have to put
the jumanji tag line on there you could
just say
jumanji um i only do one more movies
that's my new thing i love it all right
alex thank you so much uh everyone
please go see old in theaters it is out
this week and pig and pig
[Music]
i seriously think we could have talked
to him for
at least four hours
not kidding i think he could have talked
for four hours i mean he's just so
knowledgeable
yeah about movies and he loves talking
about it and he's so eloquent when he
speaks about and he's so young like you
said he's an actor director he does all
the things and he's like
it's just disgusting it's hard to like
hate him because he's such a sweet and
kind individual but he has to be because
i swear i you just want to hate him for
his talent like i'm not one of these
gracious people where i see talented
people like oh my god i'm just like i
kind of hate you a little because i'm
too much of a selfish artist to
appreciate it but he's one of the few
that make it so easy to appreciate and
love and i'm gonna hold him to that
cinephile card game like i'm gonna find
him in new york uh as you should yeah i
can i can appreciate you and i can also
be insanely jealous at the same time and
fun fact his movie the visit is 68 fresh
on the tomato meter so that's not the
movie he stars in he obviously stars in
old which is now in theaters but the
visit the movie did alex champions 68
fresh and it's 51 rotten on the audience
score which does surprise me a little
bit that that movie isn't fresh with
audiences i think it has to do too with
just what people were expecting for him
from him at that point he was doing a
huge left turn with that movie and i
just don't think it's sort of like the
reason why crimson peak
was like not great on the audience
review it just set up a different movie
than what you got and even though the
movie was great i do think that one i'm
not saying the marketing of it was bad
but it was slightly deceptive to hide
the twists
and i just think some people walked out
of it being like this was just not what
i expected yeah
well if you want to talk about a movie
that has a twist
and was not marketed the way that
maybe it should have been it was look my
movie's the village okay okay
and i picked the village and i told
producer lucy this i was like look i'm
gonna go back and watch the village
again knowing what i know now because i
was so disappointed when i saw that
movie in theaters opening day was maybe
the first movie i saw in l.a once i
moved here i was so excited because keep
in mind folks the village came out you
had the sixth sense you had unbreakable
you had signs and then the village and
the village is sold as this movie that
takes place in olden times and there's
these creatures that live just beyond
the woods that we have to please or else
they're going to come attack us and that
is how the movie was marketed we were
getting a creature feature and so you
look back and even though you know by
this point that shyamalan is going to
have some sort of twist in most of his
movies
there were twists and signs but we still
got aliens there were twists in the
sixth sense but we still got ghosts this
movie the whole twist is there's no
monsters there are no monsters to be
found anywhere it's just now we have
somebody who can't see someone around in
the woods trying to get to modern
civilization and it's a whole different
movie
having said all that that's the vitro
for me walking out of the theater
feeling like i was sold a false bill of
goods when i go back and watch it
without all the marketing crap in my
head
the village is so well done exactly it
is such a finely crafted piece of art
that is surprising on multiple levels
and i just found myself gravitating
towards the direction the performances
roger deakin cinematography jacqueline
i'm a huge fan of this movie and i was
killed it for decades for a decade after
i saw it so when did you become a fan
fan of it when did the transition happen
um three days ago three days ago yeah
three days ago wow i i could feel it
erode i could feel the hate eroding for
a number of years just because
you start to think about well what did m
knight do that was so wrong about this
movie what did the actors do what are
the people actually making the movie
dude that was so wrong and regardless of
whether he has to say in how the movie
gets marketed or what the trailer looks
like i understand that the studio is
trying to put butts in seats okay i
understand that but you also have to be
prepared where if you're selling this
movie is something totally different
than what it actually is
you can say you're trying to honor the
twist but i also know that it's going to
have a backlash because people are going
to go see this opening weekend get
something totally different than what
they thought they were getting and it's
going to affect what
the reviews of the movie are and you
look at it it's 43 rotten on the tomato
meter currently it's 57 on the audience
score which is rotten i'm surprised it's
that high i thought the audience score
would be much lower but i love the movie
because it takes place in modern day
except we don't know that because it's
this community that is deep inside this
nature preserve where even the people
who are in charge of running the
preserve aren't allowed to go into and
so it's a no-fly zone there's no ties to
the modern world and the reason for that
for people living there is because there
were people who felt like the modern
world had betrayed them in their various
lives they got together at a support
group and they said hey let's do
something radical
and when william hurt is sort of your
cult leader you believe everything he
says i mean it's just a new version of a
cult that just happens to have some
amish tendencies exactly and apparently
i i was looking to some of the research
that the great mark hoffmeyer did for us
m knight had the cast and crew live like
that for three weeks and joaquin phoenix
was telling stories about trying to
start a fire and he just couldn't do it
people
no phones no nothing for three weeks
they're just basically camping to get
those sort of reps down they were
playing fields and just from from top to
bottom i mean i forgot adrian brodie is
in it and what a different sort of
element his character lens to it how
great sigourney weaver is how great
joaquin phoenix is bryce dallas howard
there's just so many great performances
in this movie that really tie it all
together
that was when i knew that bryce dallas
howard was definitely going to move past
her father's legacy that was what i was
like because you know there's always
that hollywood nepotism like thing that
people like talk and think about but
like seeing her in that i was like oh no
no this is like a different formula like
she really brought it and what's
interesting is she's become a director
in her own right since then too uh
i will i will say this um when i think
about the village i think about the
scene where you figure it out because
it's like so visceral but like for you
mark what was the scene like if like
when you were watching it was there a
specific scene that you saw where you
were like oh yeah this is this plays
differently now i had so much
hope and i was clinging to there being
actual creatures in the woods when i saw
it in theaters and so there's a reveal
in the movie where william hurt just
basically has to tell
uh bryce dallas howard's character that
hey look there are these creatures that
there were rumors a long time ago but we
just we that's how we designed them and
he shows her the costumes that they put
on but then she's in the woods and she's
by herself now and she's still
frightened because she has these words
from him echoing in her head that there
were stories that they the old-timers
used to tell about creatures in the
woods and then you see one of the
creatures and you're like oh wait wait
wait is that it yeah
yeah we getting a creature and it's a
whole different thing right yeah
something different and and she's blind
and so we the audience can see what she
can't but she can feel everything she
can sense everything and so i i was sort
of even though i was disappointed when i
saw in theaters i was still kind of on
the edge of my seat from a hopeful
perspective what rewatching it though i
could just really sink my teeth into
okay are there any hints that they give
us as to this is modern day and the
elders know more than everybody else in
the town and it's just such a cool way
that that he made the movie it was
really really spoke to his directing
ability that he could tell a story like
that and so had it been marketed
differently i don't know if i would have
felt
that way at the time but it also would
have taken some of the punch out of the
twist and so i don't know what the
perfect balance of that was i just feel
like the studio itself erred on the side
of we need to make sure that we make a
lot of money with this movie opening
weekend
one thing i will say is i think that
when we get into my film i think i saw
it the best way to see an m night
shyamalan film we'll get to that in a
second but
i wonder when you look at the score 43
rotten and 57 on the audience score if
that bump up has come later because i
will say the village has risen in the
estimation of more than just you it is
definitely one of those movies that
people in fact i think i just saw a
tweet today where somebody was posting
the scene where they're like getting
into the underground tunnel and it's
like brody bringing her down like that
that was somebody today being like m
knight gave you all this and y'all
wanted to call him a flop and like that
to me i think sort of personifies the
problem with somebody that comes out of
the gate like coming out of the gate
with the sixth sense you know that
there's haters just waiting for you to
fail so i just feel like like by doing
what he wanted
um
i think at least he's happy with what he
did and more importantly for the people
who didn't feel it i don't think
i don't think all of it was because of
what they saw on screen and i put that
on my film split
because mine is actually pretty high on
this vader meter it's 77 on the tomato
meter and it was this movie that people
were like m night is back he was
actually back with the visit but they
were like giving him credence with it um
with split
and
i saw this film at fantastic fest as the
secret film
that they showed for um like the
festival so you don't know what the
movie is before you sit down for it and
i think at that point
we maybe had a trailer for split but i
don't think we even had a trailer i
don't think we had anything yet that
came out before that maybe a trailer so
we still didn't even know you were
walking into an m night shyamalan film
until the movie started yeah until the
movie started my question
with that is because again this is
leading up to split and and i agree with
you i think that his official comeback
pitch was the visit
because that was off the heels of of
after earth which i still defend and the
last airbender i'll throw devil in there
too because he didn't direct devil but
devil was he wrote it and produced it
and and you could even see then like no
this guy's still got his fastball with
devil but then after earth came out yeah
and didn't do his and and and was sort
of a flop and then the visit was a very
small movie that got some good word of
mouth split was his official comeback
but i'm wondering when you sat down to
see it fantastic fest nobody knows what
this movie that they're gonna show is
when m night shyamalan's name came up
what was the reaction in the crowd
because i can remember them showing the
trailer for i think devil and people
laughing when they saw his name as
opposed to the ooh
you know i mean so this is the thing and
i'm like again i drink a lot of rose so
i'm trying here but um
if i recall i do think there was a
trailer out i do think we had like a
teaser trailer for split and so i do
believe when the title card went up
people freaked out and i have to give a
complete amount of props to the alamo
drafthouse because the secret movie at
fantastic fest is sometimes really
amazing but it can get spoiled very
easily like two years before it was
actually crimson peak the movie we were
talking about just recently and that was
a movie where i saw nothing going into
it and it was perfect and
the problem was though i knew it was
crimson peak because guillermo del toro
was walking around the alamo draft house
and like the day before the secret
screening and so everyone was like he
doesn't have a movie here but he's like
walking around the alamo draft house
going to screenings everybody knew that
it was crimson peak but with split they
literally drove them
to the place
20 minutes after the film had started
screening to make sure nobody could see
him and i actually got to ask him a
question at the q a about why he wanted
to come down there and he said he's like
look austin's where the cool kids are
and i knew if i brought the movie here
and it had the reaction that i wanted to
have it i really knew that this was it
he was just like
i just knew that this was the type of
movie that i wanted to send with a true
horror head
audience and people that were just gonna
buy into it and what an achievement it
is because you talk about shyamalan
being famous for a lot of his movies
having some sort of suspenseful twist in
it this one pleases not only my movie
going sensibility but also my comedian
sensibility because this twist is a
callback to
yes what he did early in his career and
it worked absolutely and the other thing
too even with split because it is very
straightforward everything about it
gives what it is but there is a little
bit of twist on why anna taylor joy's
character and it's actually my favorite
scene in the movie when you look at all
the players that are around james
mcavoy's character because james split
is about a young man who has a multiple
personality disorder and his more uh
destructive personalities take control
and he becomes like a murderous sort of
like uh serial killer and uh he abducts
these three girls who are not friends
with anna taylor andy taylor joy but
she's uh with them at a birthday party
and the other girls who have lived this
sort of sheltered life are great but we
come to find out that on uh anya taylor
or anya taylor joy had
abuse in her childhood and it's a slow
reveal
and you can see the damage within her
actually saves her and that to me is
like also a twist in that one and it was
so well done because the scene where you
realize what's happening to her i
remember being in the theater being like
no no no no no little girl don't go in
there no no
no no it was just it was so like you
just it was like the kid you know that's
walking into the doom in the horror
movie and for not being a true [ __ ] it
just it just added so much on that but
yeah the that twist at the end with uh
spoiler alert kids uh bruce willis
popping up and you realize this is
completely part of that unbreakable
universe which also previewed the fact
that they were getting ready to join it
again by having glass
right and so i got to see this movie
super early as well i can't remember
exactly how i got in the theater but
uh i had a friend in town chris stuckman
who's a movie reviewer filmmaker he's
making a movie now which i'm really
excited to check out and he's just he's
just such a movie aficionado and a
creative powerhouse and so i'm sitting
next to stuckman in this screening that
the movie was scheduled to come out i
think mid-january and i'm and and we're
in the theater mid-december and so we're
seeing it this is like a super early
screening for this movie it's like hey
do not tell your friends um you can tell
your friends it's great but do not tell
them anything about this and
he started visibly shaking
when they're at the end of the visit or
at the end of uh split where we're at
the diner we're eventually gonna get the
bruce willis reveal but before that we
pan around to every other patron in that
diner watching the news report of this
weird thing
that they're reporting on and the music
from unbreakable kicks in and i'm just
not the score head i'm a soundtrack head
but i'm not a score head so i i can't
really pick out a score unless it's
something super john williams famous
stuckman starts shaking because he knows
that's the unbreakable music and he's
like wait wait what he was so excited
yeah and then it pans over to bruce
willis just saying mr glass and the
theater erupted that was the same thing
in in
uh at fantastic fest it was just so cool
and it's just really one of my one of my
treasured theater going experiences um
the the end of split but it's also not
just the twist because a lot of people
are like well yeah the movie's okay but
the twist i thought the movie was
stellar up to that point and to be
honest with you i thought it was a great
movie regardless of what of the
unbreakable type absolutely and what's
so interesting too at the fantastic
screening
um by the time you get to that moment uh
m knight and james mcavoy were actually
sitting in seats because basically like
i said they waited 20 minutes but then
they actually put them in the audience
and so m night got to experience that
like literally people stood up
and started doing like an avengers like
oh what and it was like nuts like huge
standing ovation
and
i just i love the ability i think for a
filmmaker to have that because like him
and jordan talks about this some
filmmakers make
moments in their movies specifically for
how the audience is going to take it and
i think when you look at m night
shyamalan as a whole and and honestly
he's had a lot of chapters and not a
long amount of time i mean what sixth
sense was 96.89
99
20 years is a lot but when you think
about how many evolutions he's had in
that 20 years with his filmography you
really am like again to your point the
kid's still got a fastball he's got a
lot left
um
it's interesting to to see like he
started
with a screenplay no one saw coming
everyone was talking about oscar
nominated
and then just is still writing chapters
and i still feel like he's maybe got
another sixth sense type moment still
left in him oh yeah i i think that that
now i i saw a quote from him that i that
i loved because he's gone off and made
different sorts of films now in his
career but i think that he sort of
embraced how most audiences have come to
know and revere him is for those more
thorough suspense movies and he likened
it to
understanding that because when he opens
up an agatha christie book was his
example he's expecting he has a certain
set of expectations yeah
when he does that he's expecting a
mystery to slowly unravel and
so if you make a movie like the last
airbender after earth where it's not
necessarily that then it might have it
might come with a set of audience
expectations that are let down as a
result and so
i i mean i can tell you all this without
ruining anything with old is that old is
it it employs some new directing
techniques or at least the matriculation
of that i haven't seen before there is
not a wasted shot in that movie and it
just feels so true to what he loves
about cinema and it really was a fun
theater experience and so i know alex
wants you to see every movie on the big
screen yes old really is one of those
movies i'm telling you kids now it
really is a fun fun watch on a big
screen look i felt the threat i'm gonna
see pig in the theater i know like like
legitimately i'm like i'm gonna have to
send back this screener because alex is
gonna absolutely come for me i heard a
lot of good things about this pig movie
yeah i really want to see it too so um
i'm down for it i'll just add this one
last thing again shout out to mark mark
hoffmeyer for our research say what you
want to about m night shyamalan but
everything comes from the pen and as a
writer and you're a writer comedians are
writers i'm a writer there is just such
a power in that and it's the thing
that's interesting is that's what he
went back to when he hit bumps in his
career he went back to the writing he
went back to the storytelling and he
just said
this is why it is and james mcavoy mark
uh had this interview with him where he
talked about he's the most prepared
director he's ever worked with and this
is james mcavoy who i've heard is like a
very prepared
actor he did it with um bill hader and
like it's a huge book and and like he
was asking bill hader it's like didn't
you read that part in the book and bill
was like i didn't read the book because
it's like huge and he's like
i read the book and he said it's like
and bill was like i've never felt more
like a slouch because he's a theater
actor william defoe is like that when
you get these like old school theater
heads that's what they love and so i
think
m knight approaches writing that way he
researches a ton and then he goes and
writes and so that's why when you get
with him on set and he's talking about
his shots
you you don't feel lost you feel like
you're in the you're in the hands of a
guy that's been to the top of everest 10
times yeah according to roger deakins
when they worked on the village together
those storyboarding sessions were long
because he plotted out every shot and
sam jackson had a cool quote because
back when he was doing unbreakable he
said that knight was just very dick
he was like a dictator on set where it's
like you do it exactly this way with
that look with that line delivery and
then he said that by the time he got to
making glass
that m knight was more like okay i trust
the actors to do
to do what feels right for you in the
scene so it's interesting to see that
you can loosen the reigns sometime and
get just as good of a result it's also
funny to note that sam jackson every
time he saw and white shyamalan in
between those two movies he would just
give him a bunch of crap because he's
like when are we making our sequel yeah
and then and then knight sent him
the movie um the split and he's like hey
hey watch this new movie i did didn't
tell him that it was gonna tie into
unbreakable and so then at the end you
know samuel jackson's like oh this is
great and then they make glass so it's
just it's such a cool kind of m night
sort of reflecting on his career and
then making it come full circle and now
i feel like audiences once again give
him the credibility that we had from the
start yeah and i hope they will add that
credibility to make themselves go to the
theater this weekend and check out old
because yeah
i just like a good old-fashioned horror
movie like that you know where fun movie
for to watch in in an audience yeah
all right that wraps it up breaking down
our filmography with m night shyamalan
but we're not done for the day because
we are actually going to transition to
our mailbag uh brian cue the music
[Music]
okay kids from a member of the ketchup
crew guillermo septimo he's from
argentina please tell me i said that
correctly if not forgive me
uh he says i wanted to propose a podcast
of rotten tomatoes is wrong about the
movie con-air and so you can discuss why
this blockbuster and classic of the 90s
but not colt who shows a more active uh
nicholas cage like he never does
uh is rotten on the tomato meter uh this
um this podcast i only propose
it after the launch of the new movie pig
greetings from argentina i love how he
made this like an actual proposal like
nobody is ever this nice to me guillermo
shout out to you honestly i think after
all of our pig talk with alex um and
yeah just i i feel like yeah we're gonna
have to we're gonna have to maybe do
this one i'm down for it i love conair
conair is a good one it's 56 on the
tomato meter so it's just out the fresh
the audience score is right in the fresh
zone at 75 percent it'd be great to have
a special guest from the movie on i
don't think john cusack is going to be
that guest i don't think he's a huge fan
of being in that movie but he's good at
it he's good in it but yeah i've heard
it called nick let me call nick i have
his cell phone number hey
we just talked to him recently joel
mears the editor-in-chief did an
interview with him that's actually up on
rottentomatoes.com and it's pretty
incredible the one thing i will say
about nick cage is he's just a man who i
think does what he wants and i really
appreciate anyone anyone that can follow
up mandy
after the filmography that he's had i'm
just like dude don't don't count this
guy out um it's so interesting another
actor who did this too um kuba gooding
jr after he
won the oscar did a bunch of movies that
people did not think were great
and he was just like i learned how to
make movies doing those movies and then
you see him come back and people versus
o.j simpson and yeah it's just so
interesting to see uh when people are
are less worried about what other people
thinks to alex's point not navel gazing
they're just doing what makes them happy
uh yeah i'm down for it also uh i really
want to talk about the song because the
drama between diane warren leanne rimes
and trisha yearwood about that hit that
did not win an oscar even though it
desperately should have is better than
like any beauty beauty influencer drama
on twitter or or or really like a conair
oh my god there is like heaps because
leanne rimes recorded the song they
didn't like it for the movie
trisha yearwood re-records it for the
movie but leanne was like because of the
way their contract she could still
release it as a single she did release
it as a single that one becomes the hit
and the conair one doesn't and it's like
this whole thing between her and diane
warren and trisha yearwood and it became
like it was like mean girls uh s
songwriting
that should be the next people versus
o.j that that should be the next like
crime story serial that we get so no
television and i'm paraphrasing all of
this we'll go into detail when we talk
about the film but yeah there's like a
whole bunch of drama behind that movie
thank you guillermo that was a great
great email yes um thank you again that
kind of does it for us today
we will be back but before we do we want
to remind all of you guys
please wherever you are listening or
watching this rate subscribe review and
also do like guillermo did send us what
you think we should be talking about
next on the podcast because we do this
podcast for you guys you guys are are
the only thing that we're doing this for
honestly because i just don't like sleep
it's just for y'all that's what it is i
love naps but i make sure that we do
this in the morning in between the gym
and then my eventual nap which is going
to feel great today because again i'm
flying up to seattle this weekend to run
the new hour eventually it's going to be
a special right now it's a it's just a
raw
hour 15 of clay that i got to chuck into
something funny you and you and your
lady you and melanie are working on your
material right now and i'm anxiously
awaiting both
we're getting in there we're getting in
there getting our hands dirty uh y'all
can email us rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com that's rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com and next week's
episode jacqueline people have been
looking forward to this for ages
we're taking a break we're talking about
the same we're not going to be there
people have been looking for us to like
not come back
we're giving the folks an opportunity is
the way i look at it you have an
opportunity next week when you would be
listening to a new episode of rt is
wrong go back and revisit some of the
ones that maybe you missed some of your
favorites we've done a bunch of star
wars movies we've done a bunch of the
big blockbusters your titanics your
armageddons we've also done some smaller
movies that maybe those are the ones you
missed and sometimes those are the best
conversations i would look at something
like sister act 2 is something where
it's like oh we're going to do that
actually that conversation literally
blew my mind so there's a lot of stuff
to go back and delve into and we
encourage you to go check out some of
your favorites tell your family tell
your friends and like and do all that
subscribe stuff that jaclyn asked you to
do yeah and for everyone quote tweeting
about the movie that you're pissed off
about from rotten tomatoes tell them
that we have a podcast this is like a
trending topic on twitter and i was
literally wanted to comment under each
one we have a podcast that talks about
this every week
what if that is white we're taking a
week break is because jacqueline and i
just have to get to the bottom of that
thread to see who started it so then we
can go from there and just remind
everybody who commented the rhyme
tomatoes was wrong about something that
there's a whole podcast dedicated to it
and we're going to be talking about
suicide squad in a couple weeks that's
our that's our big comeback the way that
enlightened shyamalan came back with the
visit we're coming back in two weeks
with suicide squad the original suicide
squad movie which is weird to say
because it came out like three years ago
before the new suicide squad movie comes
out in theaters yeah everybody got that
yeah tune in for that one the movie that
made me break up with dc all right
that's it for us i want to thank alex
wolff pertussi lucy brian perez uh
christian rubicon i haven't got to say
his name wrong christian i'm sorry
or you can just go christian ruth acaba
i had it right then i was like i had it
right confidence this is the kind of
crap that i can't do on stage in seattle
this weekend i have to sell it even if i
don't know what i'm saying next i have
to sound confident yes and you guys can
find out about that follow him he'll
have it on his website mark ellis live
yeah dot live and mark ellis dot live
very different website from what it used
to be
and uh you guys can find me at that
jaclyn all over the interwebs and we
will see you guys after our break
see you then
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you